DNA sequencing is the process of working
out the order of the building blocks or
bases in a strand of DNA before we can
sequence the DNA it has to be cut up
into smaller pieces that are inserted
into plasmid DNA
and then put into bacterial cells this
makes it possible to produce lots and
lots of copies of it as the bacterial
cells multiply the DNA is then isolated
from the bacteria and sent for
sequencing the isolated DNA is
transferred to a plate where the
sequencing reaction will take place
a mixture of ingredients is added these
include free DNA bases a C G T DNA
polymerase enzyme and DNA primers
modified DNA bases labeled with colored
fluorescent tags are also added these
are called Terminator bases
to start the sequencing reaction
everything is heated to 96 degrees
Celsius this separates the DNA into two
single strands the temperature is then
lowered to 50 degrees this enables the
DNA primers to bind to the plasmid DNA a
temperature is then increased to 60
degrees and the enzyme DNA polymerase
binds to the primer DNA
DNA polymerase starts making a new
strand of DNA by adding unlabeled DNA
bases to the target DNA it continues to
add DNA bases until a terminator base is
added these Terminator bases have been
chemically altered so that no more bases
can be added to the new strand of DNA
once a Terminator base is added the DNA
polymerase enzyme stops making DNA and
falls away from the strand everything is
then heated to 96 degrees Celsius again
to separate the new DNA strand from the
original strand
this process of heating and cooling is
repeated again and again to produce lots
of fragments of DNA of different lengths
the lengths of each fragment depends on
when a terminator base got added
you
to read the sequence of the DNA the
various fragments are separated by
length using a process called
electrophoresis a capillary tube is
lowered into each well of the plate and
an electrical charge is applied
this causes the negatively charged DNA
molecules to move through the capillary
tube each capillary contains a porous
gel the shorter fragments of DNA moved
through the gel more easily than the
longer DNA fragments
as a result the fragments become
arranged by size from the shortest to
the longest
as the DNA fragments come to the end of
the capillary a laser makes the
Terminator bases light up the color is
detected by a camera and recorded each
Terminator base is labeled with a
different color a flora sees green sea
blue G yellow and T red
the shortest DNA fragments will be read
first and the longest read last the
sequencing machine records the color of
the Terminator bases as a series of
colored blocks each colored block
represents the labeled Terminator base
at the end of each fragment of DNA by
converting the colors into letters we
get the sequence of our piece of DNA